hey guys this is andrew for
turingsenses.com so i've been working as
a professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
and i use technical analysis every day
to take any trading decision
so i decided to make a youtube channel
where i basically
try to show you guys all the tools and
techniques that i like to use
those that are efficient for me and most
importantly guys i want to show you how
to use them
so if you want to know about all the
stuff and basically if you want to know
how to make money on the markets
you guys are in the right place so today
i want to make an update on tesla let's
get into it
[Music]
so guys for those who have watched my
previous videos you saw guys that i
basically
did an update on tesla where i was
telling you
my bullish case which is very bullish
but i was telling you guys that we are
right now
in the consolidation phase which is the
fourth wave that you can
find here so basically this is iliot
formation
so i use this a lot guys to actually
find the structure of the market which
is developing in waves
and to identify uh where we are in terms
of
actual development of those waves in in
order to set up
my trades because it's gonna help me to
use all the other indicators like trend
lines of fibs
much more efficiently so here the
question
is is this market cycle complete or not
and i believe it is not
because here i can actually count five
waves
in the third wave so the third wave
looks complete
but something is missing here for me i
tried i spent a lot of time doing this
counting and
i believe that this is actually only
four and
that the fifth is gonna come so i'm
gonna give you my target again on this
uh so the question we're having now is
where actually the force wave is gonna
correct too
so i was saying in my previous videos
that my level was 530
so i found this level using fibs and it
was also the maximum levels that we had
here
so funny thing is that we went to 539
all right so some guys were just you
know
friends running me it's fine so i have
not been
executed here on this uh trade but
i don't think actually the correction
phase is over
as you can see guys i think that the
correction is gonna last
you know something like this
i think that the correction is going to
last until may uh you know
maybe one more month and i believe that
the false wave is going to be a triangle
because usually
false waves are developing in triangles
so
i'm expecting here to see this kind of
stuff you know something like this and
here
are probably we're going to have some
consolidation and guys that's why
careful it's not because we did plus 20
yesterday so
i'm doing this video on the 10th of
march guys sorry if i post it a bit with
delay
but i mean you know this is a bit
long-term analysis
at least like middle term medium term
analysis so it's fun
if like i don't have the most recent
data
but what i have is plus uh plus 19
19.6 exactly so i don't think it's a
nice level to buy guys i think that
uh we're gonna have a lot of resistance
coming here so
probably around the moving averages so
around the 750 level again
i remember remind you guys that 750 was
actually you know
i was a buyer here at 750 but uh you
know
using a stop loss around 7.30 and i was
saying that 750 has not been retested
it has been retested uh since then but
uh it's still a strong resistance i
think we're gonna go to 750 and that
we're gonna
basically consolidate here for the next
month so i don't expect tesla doing any
crazy move in the next month
but then i expect this triangle to be
broken
and then retested and then guys i would
be a
massive buyer of this and with the
target uh
much higher so let me give you my target
so to find
the targets i use fib extension that's
why guys
it's very good to associate idiot with
uh fibs
you know because elliot is telling you
where is the third wave
and fib is telling you that the fifth is
going to be a ratio of the third
so how come can you find the ratio of
the third if you don't have the third
all right guys so for those who want to
know more about uh all the stuff
i mean in that wave principle click on
the link in the description of this
video and you're going to receive a free
video
where i explain everything yes about
illiads all the different patterns how
to
how they are linked to together how to
use it i'm going to do some theory and
some practice
i'm sorry guys i haven't finished this
video yet but it's coming very very soon
and you're gonna receive it it's gonna
be like two hours of like where i
explain everything guys
and trust me this information we cannot
find it in any book
or on the internet so once you have the
third wave you measure it
and you apply it to the bottom of the
force wave so i don't know where it's
going to be the bottom but i'm pretty
sure it's going to be around 500
and then it gives me the 1.618 phoebe
extension level that is at 1950.
so if i have a breakout level that is
happening around 600
next month guys i'm gonna jump on it and
try to make this 200
insane performance in a matter of few
months guys because i think we're on a
bubble so that's why
my view is a bit biased i think uh go
check it out on my snp
nasdaq video that i did last week on the
bubbles but this is why
i am you know very bullish on most of
the hot stocks
like tesla and this is why my counting
is like this as well because i take all
this information into account when i do
my analysis
so guys that's it for me i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys